Let's do this exercise together.
Derrick, what labels
did you come up with?
>> So just like I tried to transfer
the vocabulary we used to describe
the relationships between shapes and
a figure, I decided to try and transfer
the vocabulary we used to describe
transformations between the two figures.
So just like X was
unchanged between A and
B, r is unchanged between C and five.
In this case, s is also unchanged.
It moved, but
that's captured in the relationship
between the shapes in figure five.
The shape itself hasn't changed,
so it's unchanged.
Just like dot z disappeared,
dot t also disappeared so
I marked it deleted like we did before.
>> Good, that seems like a good answer.